on this friday night
bc's volatile conditions for wildfires
the looming threats of more infernos
they have to be
prepared for this and the major sigh of
relief for one family
outrage against the catholic church over
residential schools
we're even thinking about maybe leaving
the paint up for a while just as a way
of not trying to cover this up
as statues of two queens are toppled
a 31-year veteran of the toronto police
service killed in the line of duty
while investigators say this was no
accident
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in linton bc
a village decimated by a fast-moving
wildfire
our house is to the point of almost
burning soon so
compelling stories and video are
emerging from residents who risk their
lives to save their homes and
others we're also getting a clear sense
of the damage
and it is catastrophic only charred
shells of homes and businesses remain
the bc coroner service has received
reports of two deaths
and there are still people who are
unaccounted for
the litton creek wildfire is raging out
of control it's fueled by dry
windy and hot weather conditions and
with no reprieve in the forecast
there are fears an extreme situation
could become
even more dangerous and unpredictable
[Music]
nearby railroad tracks are being kept
wet over fears a passing train
may have sparked the fire cn rail says
it's going to help authorities
in identifying the cause
the province is pledging to rebuild and
prime minister trudeau is meeting with
the incident response group today
also promising to help the community
robin gill is in merit tonight where
many residents have fled to robin what's
the situation there
first of all i want to show you the
skyline what a difference a day makes
it's very smoky here
so that shows that the fire threat has
not ended not even close
and it's very worrisome for the
residents who have actually had to flee
here because this has been deemed an
evacuation center and they're worried
that they may have to pick up again but
we do have some good news to report
about one family that was split apart
during the evacuation
for 24 hours no one knew where norman
drynock was
he had no phone there was no way to
reach him
really relieved i slept pretty good last
night
his daughter can finally breathe and
describes her father
as a hero because the 65 year old elder
was able to protect parts of the nickman
first nation community
near lytton he managed to build a guard
around nickman
and and protect homes i heard he's
really exhausted
he has his stuff packed and he should
have left nickman last night
but there are still others unaccounted
for after fire tore through the village
and gutted
90 percent of it information about
what's left of litton
is trickling back to residents who've
been on the run since the fire began
have you seen the pictures out of litton
yet oh yes
i lived there all my life and it's just
nothing you ever imagined you would see
or live through
after leaving litton roadblock after
roadblock landed john hogan in merit
now the smoke has moved into this
community and he's worried people will
have to pick up again
where are you going to lay your head
down at night this couple decided to
stay in linton when the fire began
despite the danger they lasted almost 24
hours
then the rcmp came knocking and they had
to leave but they believe
they saved their house you know embers
would land
and and we'd put them out and we just we
we just tried to save it and it
just kept working star drynock is hoping
to find
her house still intact but her family is
her first priority
it's all i wanted was for our families
to be together and
safe and i think that's
all i want all i need but it's still not
safe to go back into the community even
for those who still have homes intact
because the infrastructure still has to
be assessed
even the rcmp which needs to do a grid
search and look for those people who are
unaccounted for
can't even get in pharah there's a long
road ahead
robin gill and merritt thank you robin
most of the province is facing a high
or extreme risk of fire danger heat
warnings are in effect in several areas
where wildfires are already raging out
of control
there are 137 fires burning across bc
69 of them were sparked in the last two
days alone
and only 13 are under control
paul haysom is near linton paul what are
officials most worried about tonight
there
far there are a number of concerns wind
being a big one it is literally
changing this situation every single
moment but as of friday afternoon there
were nine
wildfires of node burning in this
province with a combined size of 60
thousand hectares
lightning that is also a concern it's
responsible for so many of the fires in
the bc interior
12 000 lightning strikes on thursday
alone
including in kamloops where residents in
two neighborhoods
were forced to evacuate now thankfully
their evacuation orders were rescinded
just after midnight
the local fire chief says firefighters
likely saved about 400 homes
and while that is good news this is not
there are currently
1300 homes under evacuation order right
now
and the next seven days do not look good
there is the possibility of more
lightning in the forecast
it is hot the heat warning is now in
effect for eastern parts of the province
and that wind is whipping a 200 hectare
fire burning near deca lake about 170
kilometers northwest of kamloops
has also prompted the evacuation of
about 700
properties on top of that smoke is
expected to be a major issue over the
next couple of days with already a
number of advisories
in place take all of that into
consideration and far
early july is typically the beginning of
wildfire season
in b.c what a frightening time for the
people there paul haysim near linton bc
thank you and much of bc is sweltering
under heat warnings including the
province's kootenai region
next door southeastern alberta could see
temperatures soar to near 40 degrees
the extreme heat is still hovering over
most of the prairies
roasting saskatchewan and manitoba but
it's pushing into northwestern ontario
daytime temperatures there could hit the
mid to high 30s
at night it could stay in the upper
teens until at least sunday
seven people including four children
have died after a house fire east of
calgary
the fire broke out just after 2 30 a.m
claiming the lives of three adults in
their thirties two twelve-year-olds an
eight-year-old
and a four-year-old one man and four
children were able to escape
the rcmp say two families were living in
the house
witnesses say flames appeared to reach
as high as 15 meters
into the air family of five
they moved here just a couple of months
ago
and the brother was visiting last night
on a canada day evening
so they were all together so the fight
broke up
in the middle of the night and the owner
of the house
he could save only two of his children
and two of his brothers
so devastating that you know they are
all gone
and we have no words the cause of the
fire is still under investigation rcmp
says
it does not appear to be criminal
winnipeg police are investigating after
two statues of commonwealth queens were
pulled down by protesters
on canada day
[Applause]
[Music]
the statue of queen victoria was toppled
and its head tossed in the
assiniboine river at the end of what was
meant to be a peaceful walk against
canada's residential schools
another statue of queen elizabeth also
located on the lawns of manitoba's
legislature
was torn down and vandalized the city's
police chief says the situation was
delicate and a decision was made not to
engage the crowd
i commend our members for their
professionalism yesterday
and their ability to preserve a safe
environment
and later their ability to de-escalate
a volatile situation that was started by
a small
number of individuals the police chief
says
several police cars were damaged after
being pelted with rocks and paint
and that officers were spat on and
assaulted
and in calgary a major cleanup is
underway after at least 10 churches were
vandalized on canada day
churches have been targeted across
canada since hundreds of unmarked graves
were found
at former residential school sites in bc
and saskatchewan
as heather urux west explains emotions
are running high
red paint remains on the doors of
calgary's grace presbyterian church
its pastor says the church is still not
sure
how best to respond we're even thinking
about maybe leaving the paint up for a
while just as a way of not trying to
cover this up
but recognizing that we have a
place in this in this story churches
across the country have been targeted in
a series of vandalism or arson attacks
in recent weeks
following the discovery of unmarked
graves near residential schools operated
by the catholic church
on twitter thursday alberta's premier
said the vandalism of churches across
alberta is appalling
this is where hatred based on collective
guilt for historic injustices leads us
let's seek unity respect and
reconciliation instead
the prime minister calls the attacks
unacceptable and wrong
we shouldn't be lashing out at buildings
that can provide solace to some of our
fellow citizens
but we should be every day committing
ourselves
each and every one of us to the hard
work we need to do
sixty first nation chief uray crowfoot
says he does not condone
any destruction of property but he also
understands
people are in pain there's a lot of
emotions
going a lot of ways there's a lot of
people that don't know how to feel now
that these children
are literally coming out of the ground
so is the emotional baggage
that the survivors put away on the
siksika first nation rcmp are
investigating a series of suspected
arsons as well
two involving churches and a third
involving a series of grass fires
believed to be deliberately set on
canada day the chief says the land
damaged was culturally significant
often used in ceremony and while it's
not clear if those fires have any
connection to the recent church attacks
it continues to be an emotionally
charged time
heather urex west global news calgary
in toronto a veteran of the police force
has been killed on the job
as morgan campbell reports investigators
say it was a deliberate act and a first
degree murder charge has now been laid
constable jeffrey northrup dedicated his
life to serving toronto spending more
than
30 years on the force northrop was a
familiar face
at 52 division where he worked in the
major crime units a role he took on
this past april after spending years
training new officers
for the fields that just speaks to the
kind of quality of officer we had
and jeff northrup was killed early
friday morning in what toronto police
are calling
an intentional and deliberate act the
veteran
officer was struck and killed in the
underground parking lot
of city hall he and his partner dressed
in plain clothes
had been responding to a robbery in
progress when they were struck by a
vehicle
toronto police say the suspect was
initially outside the vehicle
it is unclear what happened next but
police
say there were other people in the
vehicle based on the evidence we have at
this time
and i spoke to the lead investigator
from the homicide squad
it is it was a deliberate and
intentional act and that is all really i
can tell you at this point in time
both officers were rushed to hospital
where northrop was pronounced dead
his partner was treated and has since
been released
eyewitnesses described the scene as
chaotic
we saw like three special constables and
then two cars which had a collision
and we also saw that the barricades of
the parking lot they were like
broken flags have been lowered at city
hall toronto's mayor spoke of the
profound impact
the loss has had on the city the
the most difficult parts of this job are
parts that involve
the loss of life the loss of a police
officer is a searing
kind of tragedy for the whole city
police have been canvassing the area
looking for video footage in an effort
to piece together
what exactly transpired here meanwhile
northrup leaves behind
three children a wife and a mother
morgan campbell global news toronto
search crews have pulled two more bodies
from the rubble of that collapsed condo
in florida
including the seven-year-old daughter of
a miami firefighter
tonight 126 people are unaccounted for
that's down from 145 which included
duplicate reportings
four canadians are still among the
missing 22 people
are dead the mayor of miami-dade county
has ordered the demolition of the
collapse tower over fears about its
structural integrity but
hurricane elsa could further hinder the
recovery effort
it's expected to hit this weekend the
delta variant is rapidly spreading
through the uk
coming up why that surge could serve as
a warning
to canada
are you excited yeah i am very excited
prime minister justin trudeau has rolled
up his sleeve for a shot of moderna
his wife sophie did the same yesterday
in april both received astrazeneca
for their first dose in total more than
32 percent of all canadians have now
been fully vaccinated
and over 67 percent have had at least
one dose
in the uk nearly 50 percent of the
population has been fully vaccinated
against covet 19
yet it is seeing a sharp rise in cases
now the surge is being fueled by the
delta variant
and as crystal commansing reports there
are warnings canada could see a similar
spike
if people aren't careful
lots of cheers courtside at wimbledon
but few
masks the tens of thousands of
spectators on hand
must prove they're covet 19 free or
fully vaccinated
the event was granted special government
research status
but an independent scientific advisory
group is now
demanding changes to the way events are
selected
the way it's presented and indeed being
exploited
suggests to us that it's actually
creating risk and is being used
politically
daily infection rates are back to levels
not seen
in the uk since january and
hospitalizations
are rising according to our world data
tracking information
about 49 percent of the adult population
is fully vaccinated in the uk but even
then
they can become infected and while
vaccines prevent against serious illness
covid19 and its variants can still be
spread to others
german chancellor angela merkel raised
the issue of cross-country transmission
with the number of football fans and
athletes taking part in euro 2020 events
is i see this with great concern said
the chancellor adding that germany
greatly reduced the number of fans at
events
canada's vaccination rate remains lower
than both germany's
and the uk's experts say with the delta
variant
about 75 of canadians need to be
protected
before anyone should feel safe even
though we're
you know much closer to the end than
what we were at the start of the year
we've still got
a period of time to go and and until we
get to that
level of full vaccination we really
still need to be wearing masks and
taking these precautions
the precautions are exhausting but the
experts say the pandemic
is still a threat crystal gomanson
global news
london still ahead the tall volcano
rumbles back to life near the philippine
capital
stunning video of the tall volcano in
the philippines a couple hours south of
manila
the eruption launched steam and gas one
kilometer into the air
the danger level has been raised and
thousands have been forced to flee
tao last erupted in january of 2020
killing
39 people a major blow today to the u.s
olympic track team
one of their gold medal contenders has
been suspended
after testing positive for marijuana 21
year old
shikari richardson won the women's 100
meter race at the u.s olympic trials
last month
the u.s anti-doping agency says she's
tested positive at the trials
she's now suspended for one month
meaning she cannot run the 100 meter
race in tokyo
richardson has apologized she says she
used marijuana to cope
after finding out her biological mother
had died
a swim cap designed for natural black
hair types has been
banned from the olympics the
international swimming federation known
as fina has rejected the use of soul cap
a swim cap made to fit over and protect
afro hair
fina says it didn't fit the natural form
of the head
the founder of the uk's black swimming
organization responded by saying
inclusivity is realizing that no one
head
shape is normal
canada's got basketball talent next is
it enough for the men's team to score a
ticket to tokyo
canada's men's basketball team is a step
closer to booking tickets
to tokyo the team is just two wins away
from qualifying after clinching
top spot in its group and with a handful
of nba stars including
two of the most versatile shooters in
the game team canada has more chemistry
than ever before eric sorenson reports
like the emerging star lou dort rising
to the rim
canadian basketball is ascendant no one
is underestimating a canadian team with
andrew wiggins
r.j barrett and a roster of nba stars
that could make canada
a mental contender at the olympics being
able to do what you love for your
country it's an honor
veteran corey joseph is part of a team
culminating years of development in this
country and
inspired a generation ago by steve nash
and vince carter
and the toronto raptors the raptors
current head coach
leads this canadian team i think it's a
golden age for basketball
so i think the future's bright super
bright for canada basketball
injured canadian superstar jamal murray
and others not playing would themselves
make a formidable national team
such as the depth of talent canada now
has in men's basketball
a lot has been left on the table with
jamal murray being off dylan brooks
being out kelly olynyk being unavailable
but this group
itself is probably the best collection
i've ever seen canada put forth in an
international competition
the prohibitive gold medal favorites are
the americans and other countries have a
history of international success that
canada does not have
though the canadians have won qualifying
games already this week in victoria bc
against greece and china they have the
most
high talent depth outside of the united
states and if they do make the
tournament
can that talent overcome what will be a
relative lack of experience
meantime canada's women's basketball
team has already qualified for the
olympics
kia nurse and other stars likewise have
elevated the women's game in this
country
it speaks so much again just like the
men to the depth of talent that canada
has internationally
the men's team however must still win
two more games this weekend to qualify
for tokyo
in my mind we haven't done anything yet
yes we have a
talented group of players but we've got
to put it all together
basketball has become one of the marquee
events of the summer olympics
and canada now flourishing in the sport
could have both the women's and men's
team battling for a place on the podium
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm farin asser thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us
tonight's your canada is lac st anne in
west cove alberta we love seeing your
canada so please email us your pictures
at viewers at globalnational.com calling
kristy will be
with you at the anchor desk tomorrow
until monday take care of yourselves
and each other
[Music]